hi I'm Erik Bosse and Jordan peels us
much like his first film get out is
filled with subtle details that hint at
deeper meaning clues that foreshadow
later twists and Easter eggs that allude
to iconic horror cinema
I got a breakdown this whole movie scene
by scene for everything you might have
missed mainly because I just love course
in the underground Heather version of
myself to obsess over pop culture to
spoiler warning if you haven't seen the
movie yet and let's get started okay the
opening title card establishes that
there are thousands of miles of
underground tunnels across the US with
the cryptic hint that many of them are
not used in planes some of them must be
foreshadowing the later reveal of the
tunnels spanning the u.s. from which the
tethers rise up if you're interested in
this there's actually a book called
underground a human history of the
worlds beneath our feet by will hunt it
explains the real-life abandoned
infrastructure beneath the US cities but
this grid doesn't span the whole country
so you can take off the tinfoil hat now
the text singles out America to
establish us as an American story
the title us also working as US United
States and Peele suggesting that
Americans fear the other when we should
really fear our own reflections
ourselves
you may also interpret these tunnels as
a literalized version of the Underground
Railroad a network of homes that helped
American slaves work their way to
freedom similar to how these tether
slaves achieve freedom in this movie
moving on to this opening shot of the
Hands Across America ad I did another
video explaining the ending of us that
goes into the deeper symbolism of the
1986 charity event and a lot of the
other recurring imagery but here I want
to point out the other videos that you
can see on the shelves around this TV
monitor one tape is chud the cult
classic horror film cannibalistic
humanoid underground dwellers a nod to
the underground dwellers of this film
there's also the Goonies another 80s
underground adventure story that
actually gets a few nods throughout this
movie there's also a copy of the man
with two brains which could reference
both the dual soul connection of these
people and their tethers as well as get
out in which black people were kidnapped
and had their brains displaced by the
brains of elderly white people next we
see young Adelaide played by Madison
curry with her parents at the Santa Cruz
Boardwalk in 1986 her father Russell was
played by Abdul Mateen a second who
played Black Manta and Aquaman now this
Boardwalk actually dates back to 1910 in
Rio
life they didn't really have to change a
lot of the carnival sets and this
boardwalk actually features an
underground tunnel system that's used
for shelter in case of emergencies
now the dad wins her a prize in Adelaide
picks number 11 the first of many
instances of the symmetrical 1111
imagery found throughout this film the
whack-a-mole carnie wears a black flag
shirt whose logo is for vertical black
bars kind of like 1111 and soon after
this Adelaide passes the man with the
Jeremiah 11 limit a sign that Bible
verse about the reckoning of the people
Babylon much like the reckoning this
society is soon to thanks Emily its
prize is this shirt of Michael Jackson's
Thriller which is another key reference
point jackson's red suit inspired
adelaide and the tethers red jumpsuits
and Jackson's famous one glove is one of
the inspirations for their one club the
mom warns that shirt will give her
nightmares and the rest of Adelaide's
life is a nightmare
the mom also says you know they're
shooting a movie over there by the
carousel and that's actually a reference
to the 80's horror film The Lost Boys
starring Goonies star Corey Feldman
which was actually shot at the Santa
Cruz Boardwalk in 1986 down the beach
Adelaide passes some kids at a bonfire a
nod to the opening scene of Jaws which
actually gets referenced a lot in us and
she wanders into this funhouse Hall of
Mirrors where she meets her duplicate
self now this fear of reflections was
inspired by the 1960 Twilight Zone
episode mirror image which is about a
woman haunted by her duplicate which
Peale hosted the new Twilight Zone said
had a huge impact on him as a kid Jordan
field actually cameos in this scene as
the voice of the narrator inside this
funhouse and I couldn't see it but
somewhere on the walls of this place are
written the words get out now to calm
herself young Adelaide whistles the
itsy-bitsy spider another recurring
motif in this film
perhaps a nod to the way red climbs up
the waterspout one time and then does so
again to get a revenge this leads to the
opening titles featuring white rabbits
and cages now the white rabbit could be
an allusion to Alice in Wonderland in
which Alice follows a white rabbit into
an underground mirror world also you may
remember the song run rabbit run was
used in the opening scene of get out
next we meet the Wilson family with a
quick shot of their cars family stick
figures sticker notice that the lineup
order matches the way that the tether
family will later stand their driveway
now this family includes Gabe Winston
Duke a gate in Baku from Black Panther
Adelaide Lupita Nyong'o also in black
panther and a ton other movies the
daughters Arash a hottie right Joseph
and the son is Jason Evan Alex we
learned at the end of this movie that
Adelaide is actually the tether version
of herself but there are several hints
that Jason might also be secretly his
tether itself I'll point out the various
clues for both as we go along but for
now I should point out that Jason is
also the name of the famous slasher from
the Friday the 13th movies in which
Jason's mother mrs. Voorhees was
secretly the villain in the first one
jason is a Chewie mask in a jaws shirt
there's gonna be more Jaws references
later but Zora is wearing a shirt with a
white rabbit on it yes it turns out
everything in this movies deliberate at
their vacation house is a quick shot of
an old family photo in which Adelaide
looks away from the camera purposely
avoiding eye contact and the fast movie
it comes from a joint called copper pots
a nod to Chester copperpot the legendary
treasure hunter in the Goonies
now you notice Adelaide doesn't eat meat
probably because she grew up eating
rabbit meat as a kid and the tunnels
instead she nibbles on these red
strawberries kind of similar to the way
House of Williams charactering nibbles
on the fruit loops and get out ain't
right
now in these early scenes Gabe tells
Jason a knock-knock joke knock knock
who's there you yoo-hoo setting up the
tether dopplegangers knocking down their
door later on gabe also tells Zora that
she should run in the sand because of
optimal conditions make you better at
running this sets up house auras double
is faster than her because she has been
training in bad conditions underground
Jason runs off to find a magic trick
that he left from a past summer but he
doesn't remember how to use it it could
be another hint that he must have gotten
swapped with a double in a past year
Adelaide experiences a flashback to her
parents meeting with a child
psychologist established saying that she
did not speak as a kid because she was a
tether and she had to learn how to talk
now there's also a shot of her playing
in a sandbox with red lining and he
could see her lining up animal toys in
the sand in a row for the last time in
the center being yep
you guessed it white rabbit back in the
house we get a call back to the itsy
bitsy spider when Adelaide sees a spider
crawling out past eight
boy spider this also foreshadows reveal
that the real Adelaide will reveal
herself from behind her fake version
another clue shows up when Adelaide sees
Ora in a room one of the books on the
table is they came from below as
Adelaide goes through her old stuff she
finds her old toy white rabbit notice
that she spaces out for a second that's
not totally clear whether she remembers
her past and is just lying to everyone
or whether she blocked out the memory I
think it's the latter but these little
clues are triggering her memories
hunting her about her past crimes as a
kid Jason scares his sister and then he
hides in the closet
using a toy ambulance to hold the door
for shadowing their means of escape at
the end of the movie now in that closet
you can see the board game guess who in
which you tried to match the identical
face card chosen by the other player to
the ref there's also a game called
monster trap setting up this closet as a
place Jason traps his monster later on
now on the ride to the beach
Zhora brings up a conspiracy theory that
the government puts fluoride in the
water to control our minds something a
shocking number of you believe it turns
out look folks trace amounts of fluoride
in the water is not dangerous and while
the dentist tells you not to swallow the
fluoride if you do it's not going to
kill you before we even get to whether
or not it's healthy no secret government
forces are trying to control your mind
with what they put in the water the only
authorities trying to brainwash you are
here on YouTube but Adelaide shady
reaction of this conspiracy theory is
interesting because of course she is a
product of a government conspiracy a
fictional one set in this movie and late
also reveals herself when she snaps
along to the I got five on it music she
snapped slightly off rhythm and Jason
smiles and snaps syncs with her but also
off from the song another hint that both
of them might not belong in the surface
world at the beach there's an overhead
shot of the family and notice that
Adelaide shadow trails out of line with
the others another clue of her being out
of place and then we meet the Tyler
family with Josh tim heidecker kitty
Elizabeth moss in their twin daughters
Becca and Lindsay played by Callie and
Noel Sheldon now there's a really
interesting Easter egg with Josh here
but first thank you do shudder for
sponsoring this video
AMC networks shudder is a premium
streaming video service super serving
fans of all degrees with the best
selection of horror and thrillers for
only $4.99 a month or $49.99 per year
shudder has the largest fastest growing
human curated selects
a thrilling and dangerous entertainment
it's like the Netflix of horror there
are new spine-tingling thrillers
shocking Horrors and edge-of-your-seat
suspense added weekly and you'll have
unlimited access to stream ad free on
all your favorite devices including
Apple TV Roku iPhone iPad Android
devices and more sugar has a unique
collection of exclusive and original
films of series horror classics and
blockbuster hits a current shutter
exclusive is one of my favorite recent
horror films Mandy starring Nicolas Cage
I just checked it out on shudder and
it's awesome super violent super
explosive it's practically a look inside
Nic Cage is volcanic mind at any given
second also I'm super looking forward to
shudders upcoming release of monster
party on April 25th the trailer for that
looked amazing
shudders vast selection includes an
extensive international library in every
genre creature features paranormal
slashers sci-fi psychological thrillers
documentaries there's old classics like
Halloween and modern favorites like
Cloverfield in to try shudder 4 3 for 30
days just go to shudder calm and use the
promo code rockstars
that's sh u DD er comm promo code
rockstars
okay back to Josh notice how he has a
bunch of tattoos on his arms including
an antler on each arm this is another
nod to get out in which the Arbutus
family has a mounted deer head which
Kris uses to fight his way out Adelaide
mentions a kitty that she's just bad at
small talk another clue for awkwardness
with talking in general and then they
talk about growing up dancing and
Adelaide said that she peaked at 14 now
it turns out this is because it was her
double who was the natural dancer not
her she only danced because her
therapist suggested some creative
expression Kitty and Josh bicker about
their drinking and Kitty jokes might
think about murdering him sometimes and
if you pay attention later you'll see
that when Kitty's doubled alia sees Josh
his double dying outside on the boat she
silently screams flash laughs this is a
release for her now this whole beach
sequence is a direct homage to jaws with
Adelaide's paranoia playing out the same
way chief Brody's does her eyes dart
from group to group triggered by screams
they're just playful fake-outs
the same way Spielberg heightened that
scene in Jaws they end up getting
frightened by this frisbee which lands
perfectly on their polkadot blanket with
the red perfectly covering the blue
circle it's another nod to this idea of
red
about to take over meanwhile Jason digs
sand tunnels another not that it could
be a version who originates from tunnels
and then he sees this creepy man with
blood dripping from his hands now this
is the tether of that Jeremiah 11:11 guy
whose body we saw lifted into the
ambulance earlier this is probably one
of the first untethering
this guy's standing this way on the
beach because he's the first link in
this tether human chain
now when Adelaide freaks out of her
Jason having gone missing it's not just
any mother missing her son she is
worried that he followed in her
footsteps and he wandered into the
tunnel see that switch just like she did
back at the house there are a couple
more nods to 11:11 the score of the game
that Gabe's watching is 11 to 11 and the
time on Jason's clock 11:11 Adelaide
also notices Jason's drawing guys you
can't have a horror film without some
creepy kid dual notice the perspective
though Jason drew it from behind his own
body depicting his own back and his own
back of the head this could be another
clue that there's actually a second
Jason whom this kid has seen from this
angle in their bedroom Adelaide tells
Gabe I don't feel like myself and he
says you'd look like yourself and notice
how she discreetly traces some ballet
positions with her foot it's almost like
she's trying to center herself reassure
herself that she is real Adelaide or
maybe gradually prepare herself for
battle with someone who does know these
moves power goes out and Jason says this
line was a nod to the iconic creepy kid
line and poltergeist Pele said that he
wanted to evoke a similar Amblin desk
predicament with a family in danger
also notice that from this point forward
in the movie it shifts into real time
there's more fluid shots shot from a
Steadicam fewer cut edits and more whip
pans over to other characters like
you're turning your head Peele wanted to
subliminally signal to the viewer that
we are trapped in an authentic home
invasion that's unfolding in real time
the tether family forms a line mirroring
the one-one-one-one shapes and Gabe
confronts them but they never respond
Pio wanted this to evoke the scene in
Halloween when Michael Myers is under
the ghost sheep he doesn't respond to
any of the questions with each
unanswered question increasing the
anxiety that's something ain't right
Gabe asks Jason to go get the bat and
Jason asks what bat may begin tenerife
he doesn't know what things are but Sora
grabs it and notice that she's now
wearing a shirt that says oh uh forgive
my pronunciation but this is Vietnamese
translating to
ramit red whistles that itsy-bitsy
spider again as she finds the key under
the rock signaling that she is a little
girl who whistled us earlier and she
remembers where the key is kept because
this vacation house used to be hers
now the doubles of this tether family
include red the father is Abraham might
be named after Abraham of the Bible
whose children will inherit this earth
their daughter is hombre it's a Latin
word Umbra is the fully shaded part of a
shadow like part of the Earth or the
moon that's covered by an Eclipse ombre
is the plural form so her name literally
means second shadow and the son's name
is Pluto the Roman god of the underworld
now they wear red jumpsuits and this is
meant to evoke Michael Jackson and
thriller also the inspiration for the
one glove though Pele has also mentioned
that Freddy Krueger and OJ Simpson were
famous for their gloves and according to
the movies design team the tethers mass
produced these jumpsuits themselves as
for the scissors they're also
symmetrical with Pele describing how
they're made up of two parts
and they lie in this territory between
the mundane and the absolutely
terrifying
now when red moves she scurries around
in right angles because that's how she
moved down in the tunnels it's laid out
in a 90 degree grid her abrupt turns
also evoke the memorable abrupt turns
but he sprints and groundskeeper and get
out
notice that Jason is the one to
recognize who these doubles are
now if he is actually his double he
would understand who they are then red
begins to speak and her voice is cracked
and strained a nod to the damage of her
windpipe as a girl and the fact that she
never needed to talk down there
Libby didn't yell go based her voice
reportedly on Robert F Kennedy jr. who
suffers from spasmodic dysphonia the
president or the police on who
investigate somebody who is not a member
of my family and she tells her story
once upon a time there was a girl and
the girl had a shadow now this shadow
description evokes Peter Pan who
wrestled with his shadow
mischievous shadow had a mind of its own
but was still tethered to Peter they
shared their existence red has a delayed
handcuff to the coffee table at first
step of her revenge for when Adelaide
handcuffed her to the bed frame when the
tunnels and they were girls that
explains to a delay that her plan is the
untethering and she presses her face
against the glass of the coffee table
wrecking it this shot lines up
Adelaide's face with her reflection as
the two
crammed into each other the mirror glass
barrier between them breaks the same way
the barrier between these two women is
broken as the Wilsons fight against and
they flee their tethers we jump over to
the Tyler house where they are attacked
by their tether family her name text
Dahlia IO and mix io is the name from
Greek mythology and Nix comes from
Germanic mythology a half-human
half-fish water being that lives in an
underwater palace that might connect
with the twins telling Jason to pee in
the ocean but text is an even more
interesting name and notice how the
Tyler's death is set to the Beach Boys
Good Vibrations Tex was the name of the
right-hand man to serial killer and cult
leader Charles Manson who knew the Beach
Boys personally wrote a song for them
and of course Manson and his whole cult
family murdered several victims by
invading their homes just like this
Kitty cries out - Ophelia for help o
philia being their version of Alex or
Serie A philia is a Greek name deriving
from the word meaning help the twins
slaughtered bodies in the hallway
upstairs could be a nod to the shining
the famous shot the Grady twins whose
bloody bodies Danny sees suddenly in a
hallway in the Overlook Hotel now
kiddies tethered alia doesn't kill
Adelaide which is interesting it looks
like each of the tethers only want to
kill their doppelganger notice how she's
more interested in putting on Kitty's
makeup looking in the mirror she's
mirroring Kitty's vanity also she cuts
her face look she's mirroring the
plastic surgery that Kitty received and
the cutting could also be a nod to dolly
as possible namesake the Black Dahlia
the case in which a woman's face was
mutilated after the Wilsons killed the
tether tyler's they sit shocked at the
table in front of Jason noticed the bowl
of Froot Loops
it's another nod to the memorable scene
and get out they escaped in the cars
oars behind the wheel she ends up
fending off for the attackee nombre by
distracting her with windshield wipers
and launching her off the car Adelaide
goes to check on the girl finding her
mango body in the tree and noticed how
Adelaide reacts with sympathy she tries
to calm the girl as she dies it could be
because as it's Heather herself she
feels a connection with her might also
see how this moment parallels Kris going
to check on the deer and get out
parallel runaway victim that he feels a
bond with next morning the Wilsons find
their car on fire with Pluto luring them
into a trap you'll notice in the second
half of the movie that Adelaide's white
clothes are covered in blood throughout
the film her clothes transition from
pure white to red
to reflect the revelation that she is
actually her tethered self read Jason
lowers his mask and says it's a trap and
even though this is Chewbacca there's no
way this isn't a reference to Admiral
Ackbar
it's Jason backs up and tricks Pluto
into burning himself
Adelaide says no like with um brace she
feels the connection to this kid red
snatches Jason and lers Adelaide down
into the tunnels
notice how the first thing Adelaide sees
before venturing down the rabbit hole
another white rabbit down the tunnel
classroom red explains her plan of what
her whole existence was in the tunnels
we see how she used the cultural
influences that she remembered the
moment she got trapped down there
thriller and hands across America she
used these to stage her uprising and she
says the words it's our time now which
is the mana nod to the Goonies Mikey's
big speech to rally his friends in their
tunnel here's our time it's our time
down here as red stalks peel frames her
with Adelaide creeping up behind her so
that both are in focus it creates this
unnatural visual and which neither woman
takes greater priority than the other
they're finally on equal ground in this
final battle plays out like a ballet
composer of this film Michael Abel's use
the notes of I got five on it but he
took inspiration for this composition
from Tchaikovsky composer of The
Nutcracker
on the tracklist this song is called
pasta do real sorry about the
realisation it means duet it's a
reference to Tchaikovsky's past to do in
the Nutcracker
during this ballet battle red uses her
expert choreography to remain in the
shadows it creates this visual of
Adelaide literally fighting her own
shadow but in the end Adelaide is
victorious and as she kills red she lets
out this primal animalistic scream this
is her true tether self emerging finally
then she looks right at the camera and
gives us this creepy smile this smile is
echoed in the final shot as Adelaide in
the family Drive in the ambulance over
the hills past the human chain of
tethers Adelaide locks eyes with their
son Jason and then as the sequence
reveals that she is in fact the true
tether she leaves us again with a sneaky
grinned just as Reds master plan was
inspired by thriller so is this moment
the final shot of that music video
showed Michael Jackson in this seemingly
happy ending
turning back to the camera with an
ominous smile hinting that he is
actually the villain and evil has
triumphed and if you believe that Jason
is also as tethered
the Underground has triumphed over the
surface world here as well there are
many ways we can interpret this final
image of red-suited tethers victoriously
lining the countryside politically
socially but the revelation of
Adelaide's treachery suggests that the
hero we see ourselves in might actually
be the villain wasted fear comment down
below with your favorite moment from us
and follow me on instagram and twitter
at EI vas and subscribe to new rock
stars for deep dives into everything you
love and if you plan to go to VidCon
this year we would love to join you so
please tweet at VidCon to let them know
that you would love to see us host a
panel live show meet and greet come on
let's be friends thank you for watching
and in case you're wondering I'm a
normal Eric
[Music]